On this episode of the Free Pilot
Training Channel, we're going to be
discussing the different types of
airspace.
This is a really important subject for
pilots to learn because we need to know
the different rules, weather minimums,
and equipment requirements for the each
type of airspace.
We have different types of airspace to
keep aircraft separated and to keep us
from hitting each other.
There are four basic types of airspace:
controlled, uncontrolled, special use,
and other.
In this lesson, we're going to focus on
controlled and uncontrolled airspace.
But we are going to discuss those other
two in a future lesson, so be sure and
subscribe and hit the bell notification
so you don't miss out on that.
Let's take a look at the six classes of
airspace you need to be familiar with.
We've got Alpha, Bravo, Charlie, Delta,
Echo, and Gulf.
By the way, unless you've already done
so, you will need to memorize the
phonetic alphabet. Don't worry about the
numbers or the Morse code there, but try
to memorize this as soon as possible.
Like I said, we have six classes, but we
have two types: controlled and
uncontrolled. Classes A through E are
controlled airspace.
This means we can receive radar services
from ATC. And if we're receiving those
services, we're under radar control.
Now, we will use these services, too,
but it's specifically designed to keep
people who are flying on instruments
safe.
Class G airspace is uncontrolled
airspace. You can remember this by
thinking G for government free.
Aircraft in class G airspace are
typically not under radar control.
Now, let's take a quick look at each one
of these.
First, let's take a look at class Alpha
airspace. That's this red area here.
We're not going to spend too much time
talking about this one because you need
to be on an IFR clearance to be up here,
among other things. But you do need to
know that class Alpha airspace goes from
18,000 MSL to flight level 600. That's a
pressure altitude of 60,000 ft. By the
way, you heard me correctly. This is
18,000, not 18,000.
From now on, when it comes to altitudes
of 10,000 ft and above, we need to
annunciate them this way.
For example, instead of 10,000, we
should say 10,000.
This is 11,000, 12,000, 13,000, and so
on.
We don't ever want there to be confusion
at which altitude ATC wants us at.
If you're wanting a good way to remember
class A airspace, remember A is for
above. This airspace is above where we
can go as VFR pilots.
Now, let's take a look at class Bravo
airspace, which here is depicted as this
yellow upside down wedding cake. Class
Bravo airspace is really busy airspace.
You'll see this around really big
airports like Dallas-Fort Worth and
Chicago O'Hare. A good way to remember
this is that B stands for busy.
Class Bravo airspace starts at the
surface and typically goes up to 10,000
ft AGL.
In the next lesson, we're going to
really dive into the details on class
Bravo airspace. But for now, just
remember that we need to be specifically
cleared by ATC to go in there.
Class Charlie airspace is crowded, but
not as busy as class Bravo.
It's also shaped like an upside down
wedding cake. It is smaller though, and
that upper level is typically only 10
miles in diameter.
This airspace starts at the surface and
goes up to 4,000 ft AGL. Remember, C is
for crowded, and we also have to
communicate with ATC before we can go in
here.
Next up, we have Delta airspace.
Typically, class Delta airspace is
shaped like a cylinder.
It's usually 5 miles in diameter, and
it's around smaller towered airfields.
This airspace starts at the surface and
goes up to 2,500 ft AGL.
The D here stands for dialogue because
we need to talk to their tower before we
can go in their airspace.
Next, let's look at class echo airspace.
You can remember this airspace by
thinking E is for everywhere else.
That's because class echo airspace is
controlled airspace that's not
designated as alpha, bravo, Charlie, or
delta.
Most of the time, echo starts at 1,200
AGL and goes up to the bottom of class
alpha.
Sometimes in busier areas, echo will
start at 700 AGL, though.
Probably the biggest thing new pilots
forget is that class echo is controlled
airspace. Just remember, we can get
radar services here, so that makes it
controlled airspace.
The last type of airspace we're going to
look at today is class golf. As I
already mentioned, G is for government
free because this is uncontrolled
airspace.
Also remember, G is for ground because
typically you see class golf up against
the surface.
Basically, class golf is everything
that's not alpha, bravo, Charlie, delta,
or echo.
And it's the least restrictive of all
the airspace classes.
I hope you guys got some really good
training today. Please hit that like
button for me, and I'll see you in the
next episode.